مشروع قبه الدمام الرياضيه خدموا احد
مبادرات الاتحاد السعودي للرياضه للجميع
لجعل السعوديه وجهها حيويه لمختلف
الرياضيات عن اللغوي
[موسيقى]
مسارات للانشطه البدنيه اجتمعت تحت قبه
الدمام الرياضيه بعد تجهيزها بوسائله
متطوره تمكن روادها من ممارسه رياضه
متنوعه من شانها ان تخلق توزنا بين
النشاطين روحي والبدني ابرزها كره القدم
كره الطائره وكره السله والعديد من
الانشطه الرياضيه التي تتيح الفرس الرياضه
للجميع طبعا القبه الرياضيه همم الاماكن
الصراحه اللي توفاتها عندنا هنا في الدمام
وجده جميله لانها عندها همم كذا ملاعب
رياضيه وفي نفس الوقت تقدر تستخدمه كذا
رياضه زي عندنا هنا لكره الطائره طبعا
سجلنا وتوني جايين وصراحه المكان مره مرتب
والحلو في اكثر واكثر ان في همم مختلف
الجنسيات والشباب اللي تونت تعرف عليهم في
الفتره هذه فصالات المره يجيء جميل
متحمسين نكمل اكثر من اللعبه هذه والله
شغل مرتب وهمم شيء حلو انه يشوف شيء زي
كذا في السعوديه هو موجود من اول بس ما هو
بشكل يعني التيشير زي كده شغل مرتب وتنظيم
والله تستهدف القبه الرياضيه الى الجنسين
من كافه الاطياف العمريه كما تقدم القبه
وبرامج رياضيه متخصصه للممارسين وللمختصين
للتمتع بحياه اكثر حركه ونشا طبعا انا
مسجل اثنين من الابناء عندي هنا في الدوم
التابع همم الاتحاد الرياضي للجميع طبعا
المكان جدا جميل ومتواجد في ضمن الحي
السكني اللي احنا ساكنين فيه التجهيزات
جدا جميله المدربين المتواجدين يعني شيء
رائع جدا اتمنى انه يستمر ويكون موجود في
كذا منطقه ان شاء الله
الرياضيه عشان تتعلم من اصدقائي وتعلم لعب
كره القدم وندرب يعطيك تدريبات منتزه روحي
من اكون العب في المنتخب
الرياضيه هي احدى الفضاءات المجتمعيه التي
تتيح ممارسه الانشطه اليوميه وفقا خطط
الاتحاد السعودي للرياضه لخلق مواقع حيويه
متاحه للجميع دون استثناء وتمتلئوا بها
الساحات العموميه في المناطق الاكثر كثافه
سكانيه من الدمام العربيه